[Musique]
tiens au fait j'ai un bon jour vous
souhaitez avant de quitter sa part de ma
cousine germaine de cousine germaine ma
cousine germaine good german la cousine
germaine ne se connaît pas mais ici
elizabeth may presse avoir cédé à bétou
germaine c'est elisabeth après-midi
germaine le produit germain mehdi ma
cousine germaine je produis qu'elisabeth
s'appelait germaine non mais vous m'avez
laissé entendre que germaine sable
elisabeth pas du tout j'ai dit ma
cousine germaine nous avons eu je
connaissais pas oui ce à quoi j'ai
ajouté elisabeth non je répète c'est
elisabeth germaine sainte élisabeth
alors pourquoi me parlez-vous autre
cousine germaine pas parce que elisabeth
c'est ma cousine germaine locaux
l'appeler vous elisabeth parce que c'est
son prénom prénom qui ma cousine
germaine alors germaine c'est son nom
non non non c'est robert robert cailliau
pour une femme robert sait pas plus
curieux que le nom de mon tonton qui
s'appelle comment votre montant martin
votre tata martin fafard martins et
féminin est alors alors je ne comprends
pas quand on s'appelle martin oui bien
sûr enfin écoutez si on va par là où ça
mais non tu te façon de parler j'avais
pas si on va par là ma cousine germaine
s'appelle denis robert et son mari marc
robert et maintenant que son mari mais
évidemment ce qu'elle allait épouser
bahrami faisait vous avez de tonton
pourquoi ça ferait martin qui s'avisent
a bêtement germaine qu elle germé à la
fin de votre cousin robert non non non
vous n'y êtes pas du tout je prends deux
cousines germaines n'est pas jean
germain il alors comme ceux tels le
bonjour qui sert votre cousine germaine
elisabeth germaine mais enfin non de 2
ce n'est qu'une cousine comment
s'appelle-t-elle elisabeth alors
pourquoi larbodie salon gbodossou était
d'elisabeth parce que m'avait interrompu
interrompu mois à la radio puis - avait
interrompu entre germaine elisabeth
alors finalement la can et de moteurs
bonjour germaine ou les abris elizabeth
alors on dit simplement c'est elisabeth
c'est elisabeth et votre cousine
germaine est fâchée elle est pas fâchée
parce que nous souhaitons bonjour alors
sainte-élisabeth vous gâcher quelque
chose non non vous allez peut-être aussi
dure qu'une oreilles de sourds mieux
s'arrêter
d'ailleurs moi aussi j'ai un bon jeu
vous souhaitez la part de king part de
serge s'est réjoui serge qu'elles
servent aux cousins germains
je connais pas ça m'étonnerait pourquoi
c'est le frères d'elisabeth
[Musique]